what's up reject nations going on yes
John coming action with me is Tony guilt
was so easy i played fallout3 but that's
about the only fallout I've played so
like you go from making fallout 4 and
then you just jump to 76 no new vegas
we're not were not new vegas for was
really fun I'm just excited to see what
they can actually add to this I love
finding out what city they're in next
and stuff just to see the destruction of
whatever city you're gonna be in well
now I'm wondering cuz this is called
fallout 76 so either we're gonna get
like a whole 70 different prequels to
this or is this maybe gonna take place
like right on the eve of the Great War
or something we're gonna go back and see
how this all came to be mm-hmm just love
being in the wasteland the bomb Oh
[Music]
finding the wholesome the completion of
both 76 this sprawling underground
shelter may have been engineered by both
tech but it was built by you so that if
the bombs do come our way of life will
the door
[Music]
[Music]
but when the fighting is stopped in the
fallout settle the entire man's he must
rebuild whoa not just walls not just
buildings but hearts stopped flying
endless and ultimately America itself
in volt 76 our future begins seems like
a lot with a lot of the trailers dozen
dropping right now they're just like you
know we're gonna show you the landscape
we're gonna show you how beautiful this
looks for open-world game like this I
get a little less bummed out about that
because part of the charm like you know
we were joking about before the video
even it's just exploring all these
different worlds cuz the following games
especially that mix of post-apocalyptic
nuclear fallout but it's also kind of
retro and then you have these mutant
creatures I love the tone of this
trailer over all the really quaint song
going over everything there's gotta be
like a little bit of quaintness when
you're not being assailed by horrible
monstrosity almost felt like the tone of
like a cowboy movie when I was watching
it and I was just like this is after new
kids but we're still going a little
cowboy style the music it did make me
feel like it was really peaceful looking
around this like nuclear waste area
after like the bombs went off yeah it
makes you feel like life's maybe not all
terrible what the hell was that
death clients know I like the craziest
thing in that game for me so if they're
gonna make like a more advanced one like
one wings or that mutant walking around
during the trailer I've wondered that I
always get distracted by that games are
different but when prequels have like
crazier stuff than you know is gonna
happen later yeah it just looks so
beautiful I already want to check out
like different areas in this game they
usually make the map so big after like
about 80 hours of playing you're all
like oh yeah now I could do missions and
stuff cuz I finally explored this area
they said like this game is four times
bigger than the last game there's
something my goodness probably would
stick to story mode right off the bat
because I feel like for Fallout games
the story mode is only so long it's a
good part of the game but really the
aspect is just like full-on exploring
finding out things finding new things
that you've never seen this is gonna be
an all online game I guess right you're
gonna be able to like actually co-op
with other people that's a complete
game-changer because you're always just
so used to simulation if it has a
similarity to a certain game like
destiny for how they put people in the
game online in those games you don't
really interact with anybody it's not
like you could
physically go up in Harlem and stuff I
was so ready for something new as in a
co-op mode or something like that just
to know that there are more people
playing it because every time I've ever
played this game it's fun but you just
know that you're just playing in a world
where there's definitely nobody else in
there with just you it'll be cool to
just see like the different things that
other people are doing just a game
changer for this yea dude one at least
from the announcements they made it
sounds like you're gonna be able to
co-op with some of your friends but
there's also gonna be people who are
looking to steal your stuff or take your
land or whatever it's gonna be a
double-edged sword to the online portion
oh it is if it's not like GTA cuz I
swear I cannot play online without just
game blasting sounds like they're gonna
limit the access to like a small group
it sounds like yeah if they do that I
mean it makes sense because it's an
apocalypse
so she can just like I know we have
millions of people yeah fully populated
ID in this nucular war well that's
exciting too is like going back to like
one of the first vaults and seeing the
world freshly decimated by nuclear
holocaust as dreary and drab as some of
the landscapes and stuff are in this
game and as cool as that is cool to see
some splashes of color and some really
rich environments that haven't corroded
quite as much as a lot of the other
games with the map like you really get a
good feel of how big it's gonna be
there's just so much of a distance it's
an endless exploring games haven't
really been doing this a lot I feel like
for the Fallout game they could do this
make the map and there's always seems to
be a little extra but you know you can't
go there if they already built a
gigantic map I could only see them
adding on a little bit more Virginia to
choose from I might even get regular
Virginia's about to add a little bit
more of that fun to your game I'm just
thinking about how lost I'm gonna get
into this game and all of a sudden would
be like oh [ __ ] two months has gone by
mmm I need to get out of my [ __ ]
house alright peace let us know your
thoughts in the fallout 76 trailer down
in the comments below are you excited to
go back to Virginia and kill death claws
and stuff let us know and as always you
can subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell to get updated
every time reviewer videos out because
you know the subscribe button doesn't do
that trizzie on instagram right right
following me followed Tony and give me
some love we're on patreon as well
full-length TV show and music video
reactions all kind of fun stuff over
there we'll catch you on the next one
peace have a good one